ladies and gentlemen Miguel McKelvey
[Applause]
morning that's a really huge picture I
said I told people to never use that
picture ever again because I've seen it
so many times and I'm tired of looking
at it but I guess no one got the memo
um I'm super happy to be here this
morning I don't know if I've ever spoken
to a group this large but and in this
beautiful of a place so it's an it's an
awesome opportunity I the other part of
this is that I don't normally prepare
for these things I like to just come out
and kind of like seems like Casey did
just talk about the things that are on
my mind but in this case these guys
challenged me to say something that's
actually meaningful and relevant to you
guys so I've tried to put together
something that that will have impact
we'll see if it works out but um but
there is a little bit organization which
I'm not used to so a little bit about me
I'm an entrepreneur from the early
dot-com days I started my first company
in 98 it was a social network for people
learning English as a second language it
still exists it's called English baby
and and so really I came out at a time
when when you know much like today where
entrepreneurs are celebrated and while
it's studied architecture in school
there was kind of was a feeling that
anyone could start a company no matter
how smart or not smart or experienced or
inexperienced you were and and I got a
very early experience with starting
something and going through the process
of trying to create something from the
ground up and I think that was an
incredible opportunity to explore myself
and figure out who I could be but it was
also an amazing challenge because there
was no mentorship there was no one to
help there was no one with any
instructions there was a time when you
had to figure everything out for
yourself and I've always remembered that
and a lot of the spirit that that that
that you had at that time is self it's
you trying against the world in a way
you trying to make something happen
trying to bring something new to life
and when we first started we work we
felt like we could create an environment
where we could remove some of that
isolation where we could create an open
place and a supportive place for people
who wanted to do these things in the
world and we believed that we would all
be stronger together that if we were
open to each other for interested in
each other's journeys if we wanted to
lend a hand and there was a forum in a
community that would allow that to
happen in a in an ongoing way whether
it's you know through events like this
or or just you know in an afternoon over
a cup of coffee that creating that rich
environment would be better for all of
us so hopefully some of you guys have
heard of we work hopefully some of you
guys will actually hopefully all of you
guys are members that would be awesome
if you're not joined tomorrow best
advice for any business of any size but
we started about seven years ago and
we've achieved some success so far we're
in cities all over the world we have
over 120,000 members I think you know
one of the coolest things that we've
achieved is we have United a community
that is in China Korea Australia all
over the US across Europe tel-aviv and
now in South America coming soon in
India and what we're finding is that
people like you on people like us people
who are connected to this idea of being
creators of trying to bring new things
to life that they're everywhere and it's
a bomb that we share when we're at this
place in our life where we want to take
hold of our future and that bond is
something that crosses all boundaries I
think from political to cultural when
you have that in yourself it's something
that allows you to connect with others
so we work is hopefully a platform for
anyone who's in that position we've been
lucky to bring people together in
business context many different kinds of
business
we started with small entrepreneurs and
startups but now we're working with some
of the biggest companies in the world
from you know big tech companies to
banks etcetera and we're all trying to
unite this same spirit of innovation and
creativity and really just positivity
for for this for these challenges that
we're all facing so to get a little more
specific about Who I am in the journey
that I've been through to get where
where I am now and really where we are
now as a company I have a few sort of
specific lessons and the first one is
that my co-founder and I Adam are
extraordinarily extremely different
people I came to New York City from
Oregon
with an idea that I wanted to achieve
something in the world I didn't know
what it was but I felt like New York was
the place to do it and one random after
Saturday afternoon I met this guy who
was brash Israeli who well I'm from
Oregon and for those of you from the
west coast especially from here you know
we're like chill and like for the most
part relaxed we have our own vibe and
when I go to New York City I run into
this guy who's like the exact opposite
literally all energy all the time always
hype always excited and and with tons of
exuberance and really no fear whatsoever
in any context willingness to do
anything at any time and when I was
exposed to him I had certainly a lot of
discomfort but I also knew that well a
lot of discomfort um but what I also
knew is that there were things that he
could do that I could never do I was
clear from the start that there were
there were things about him that
especially in the business context there
was no way I could do and one of those
things certainly is sitting in front of
a group of investors and asking for
money at a 100 million valuation or five
billion valuation ten billion you know
now we're above that I knew I would
never be that guy but I knew in him that
he was he had a certain capability and
so this profound difference was
attractive to me but I also knew that it
was going to be hard for us in a
business partnership because we approach
things from totally opposite ends of the
spectrum and so one of the things when
we decided to come together and form the
company we knew this about each other we
knew that we were going to approach
things differently and so we agreed
early on that we would always agree that
we would we would always come to a
decision where we would consider each
other's perspective and we would not
necessarily meet in the middle but we
would make sure that we were both in a
place where we're comfortable with the
solution and what that did which was
profound was that because we knew the
other one would have to agree and we
knew that we couldn't move forward until
we agreed it meant that we were always
thinking of the other's perspective
before the other one even said it and so
we would almost walk into the room
offering each other the opposite
person's perspective it's like we'd
already thought through it so much that
we'd already come to a resolution and so
over the last really 10 years that we've
been working together
it's been almost always smooth sailing
because we never we already had worked
through it and come to a the right
middle ground before and so I think
that's an important thing especially
when you're looking for a business
partner a co-founder clothes executive
team members one to look for people that
are different than you that have
different perspectives that are going to
fulfill some of your deficiencies but
then also create a structure that
respects the fact that you're different
and in our case you know create a
structure that ensures that you're going
to be able to move forward and so the
lesson here is you know never leave a
room without an agreement and and to add
to that
never let a conflict go beyond the
conversation go beyond the moment
because no one wants to carry negativity
and and in conflict once you come to a
decision
you're willing to to live with it and
move on so that therefore the business
can - second thing which of course then
you guys are engaged in the struggle you
know it's hard and certainly when you're
in the early stages of a company that
there's people doing a lot of things on
their own so you might have you know one
founder one key team member totally
responsible for an entire component of
the business mad someone working on
product and I have someone working on
sales someone else on say finance or
marketing or even two founders just
three founders whatever it is split in
half one one person doing this one
person doing that and it's really hard
sometimes to see the other person's
perspective if you're not working on it
if it's not your world and and for us
one of the things that was challenging
early on is that we've had you know the
product side we had we're building out
these buildings and we there we wanted
to make them really cool we want a
beautiful design we wanted the the best
you know sofas you could get in our
spaces but we also needed to build
extremely fast a big part of our
business model and the success of our
model was to build quickly and to
execute really quickly and so there was
always this tension between how do we
get the best product but how do we do it
extremely quickly and how do we deliver
the best experience to members how do we
ensure that no matter what we open on
the first of the month when they're
going to move in and so we would have
arguments about you know very specific
things that affected that that that back
and forth and what we found was the most
important thing for us to solve that and
to get through those challenges was to
involve asthma involve each other in
them more specifically and so for us the
cool thing is that we have these
openings you know well in the beginning
every six or eight months and now we
open anywhere from 10 to 15 buildings a
month but but the opportunity there was
to involve each other and involve the
whole team in these openings and so you
had people in every part of the company
taking part whether that was painting
walls whether
that was you know making coffee the
morning that members moved in whether it
was taking the mugs out of the box and
putting them on the shelves whether in
some cases it was doing art projects
painting murals but it allowed someone
in who was working on Finance someone
who was in legal to take part in this
collective and it broke the silos
between us it allowed us to understand
each other better and to and to see each
other in a different context than the
normal day-to-day work environment so I
think the lesson that's important is you
can you can do better as a group when
you know each other better when you
experience each other emotionally in
different in different ways and the best
way to do that is to get everyone
involved at some time so look for the
challenges in your business where you
can actually assemble a group and take
it on together the third thing which
this one was a funny one to remember was
when we when we first started we were
lucky enough to start we work with our
own money for lack of a better term and
we were brash we were pretty pretty
confident ourselves and what we could
accomplish and we did pretty well in the
in the beginning our buildings were
really successful members came in and
joined us and the buildings were
profitable you know in the way that they
operated so we were confident in our
model and and we were lucky to to get
support from some early sort of angel
investors and so one day we got a call
or an email but anyway um so we get this
this inquiry from this guy who says hey
I'm with benchmark capital I was
visiting one of your buildings today
some of my portfolio companies were in
your building and I was I really loved
the environment you know are you guys
looking for investment and we're like
benchmark capital I don't know like we
look at their website oh yeah a
benchmark capital and like legendary VCS
who have obviously now are supporting
some of the best companies in the world
but certainly their history you know
they were
one of the early supporters of eBay and
made billions etc and so you know they
invited us to come out and pitch to them
and Adam and I we thought it was pretty
cool to go to Silicon whatever it's
called the the valley um and pitch but
it wasn't like we didn't feel like we
needed them we just thought it was a
cool opportunity to pitch and go to Sand
Hill Road and do that whole thing and
and so we we made the pitch and
apparently they liked us because shortly
after they they they said they wanted to
invest and we were thinking what's the
valuation you know what are we what
should we say
and I think Brown number one hundred
million sounded good but then you know
just because we always want to push it
we've said I think 110 is better you
know 110 percent right that's what we
should be aspiring for benchmark I think
was more thinking like 70 million I
don't know seventy five so we had some
distance between us and there was a
moment through the negotiation where we
were you know we had been back in New
York we kind of forgot how cool it was
to sit in front of them and and we
actually were considering you know if
they're not going to agree with our 110
where maybe we just won't do it and
because we felt so strong and so
confident in our business we were
confident in who we were and we also
felt like we we impressed them so much
of the fact that they wanted to invest
at all meant we should stick to our guns
and try to get the 110 and I remember
the moment where Adam and I sat down and
something came over me and I realized
with all this ego and all this feeling
that we should win this that we were
probably missing what's really important
and we're probably missing the fact that
the value that benchmarks will provide
as a partner is so much more important
than this valuation and in that moment
it was a total flip it was like we
should indulge in this opportunity and
think of it as something that's part of
a much bigger picture and that this
valuation when we get to where we want
to go and where
big as we want to be when we feel like
we're taking on this global opportunity
that this negotiation isn't going to
matter and I think this was you know an
11 p.m.
discussion that it really just switched
everything I think we said yes we did
actually not agree with their evaluation
but I think we're a hundred million
post-money which still pretty good for
anybody who gets to 100 million
valuation I think you would feel pretty
successful but for us I think again
thinking really big we always believed
it was just a small step towards
something much larger so my time is
running out so I'm going to speak much
faster actually I'm going to blame the
microphone failure and take an extra
minute but um one of the other things
it's important you know especially at
hustle common with this idea of hustle
is that when you're an entrepreneur when
you have this burning fire inside of you
to accomplish something to solve a
problem you know you you you have fuel
you have something that probably is
pushing you probably wake up in the
morning feeling like you're going to
change the world but you're going to
make an impact that you're going to do
something that means something to the
world
and that can be overwhelming both for
you and for the people who are around
you and for us Adam and I were both the
people who had no off switch
I mean Casey mentioned sleep I've been
lucky enough to not sleep much for the
past 20 years I think Adam is able to
sleep intermittently depending on you
know what what um what few minutes is is
for kids and huge business allow him to
find that that time to relax but but
what we realized early on was that this
unlimited energy that we had it was
inspirational to the people who were
around us and people followed us and
loved to be a part of it but then a
month two months three months into it
they would come many of them would come
and say my whole life is falling apart
oftentimes in tears and because I'm the
like West Coast chill dude
they're mostly coming to me with that
conversation so I would be you know in
this position is saying you know I'm
sorry I'm sorry this is so hard for you
people would be saying I've sacrificed
my entire life for this company you know
I broke up with my boyfriend or
girlfriend you know my relationship with
my family I haven't seen anybody I
haven't taken vacation that you know I'm
I'm overwhelmed by this and what we
realized is that no matter who we are as
founders and for those of us who are
true hustlers and may have that
unlimited energy the culture of the
company has to be healthy you have to
start with a way to balance that you
need it as part of who you are from the
beginning you need to give people of
diverse backgrounds of diverse you know
family situations the opportunity to be
their authentic selves in your context
and so you need to figure out how to
create that environment that's going to
help them be successful and and it's
something you should think about from
day one what is the culture you're
trying to establish and and how do you
make the people on your team feel valued
and valued as whole people as as their
full selves not just for what they can
contribute for business objectives and
the last one and this one is I think
simple but also important is that when
Adam and I started we had done other
things
Adam had started other companies like I
said I started one and I was working as
a designer and architect and we started
we work we felt like we had an
opportunity to pursue our full potential
you know when you're starting your
company you can think of it as solving a
problem and that's great if you can find
a problem to solve and maybe you can
create a company and then sell it okay
there's something to that but a better
aspiration for you would be create the
company that best reflects who you are
and what your capabilities are and what
your potential is make it a forum for
yourself to grow and change and evolve
and learn because who gets to create
their own job it's very few people in
the world gets a form that their own
work environment almost everybody works
for somebody else but you start
something you can make it the best place
for you and if you think of it long-term
you could imagine your journey being for
life and so when we started
we said this is a hundred year adventure
we're also pursuing Life Extension so
that way we can get to the hundred years
but but for real from the start we felt
like it was our last job and what that
did was it said this is a journey this
is not a destination we're not trying to
raise a certain amount of money it's not
about series ABC it's not about going
public it's not about IPO it's not about
exit that's never been part of our
dialogue never and instead it's been who
are we as people what's the path that
we're on how are we growing and changing
how are we evolving and how are we
creating the context for us to be our
best selves and then similarly for our
team members as they join us and they
become a part of this how do we make it
the best place for them for them to find
their path toward self-actualization for
them to become their best selves in our
context and that's truly one of the best
aspirations you could have as an
entrepreneur is to create a place where
people are pursuing a great future for
their for their selves for their
families for their their being and for
the world so thank you guys for having
me and hopefully these five things are
helpful
oh I forgot we're opening in Auckland my
team will tell me if I don't say that
- coming I think in December so thanks
guys